happy Saturday reject nation it's Greg
Alva here and it's John Humphrey over
here John you're looking quite
incredible this morning as you drag
Incredibles to teaser trailer dropped 13
years later I'm sure this teaser trailer
will give us nothing except for a
confirmation that they're making this
movie that's all I need that's all I
need to know for sure after we're done
talking about this teaser trailer patron
of the day shout out for Rosa Parra I'm
excited in some way let's go check it
out
[Music]
whoa the anthers bears blossom
[Music]
me too summer 2018 we only have to wait
seven ish more months what a good heads
up Disney is killing it man
Disney is killing it with the superhero
genre yeah the super fantastical genre
huh
I'm excited for The Incredibles to come
back especially because of that wait a
minute it's been like 13 years I heard
this movie is picking up like
immediately after the first one cuz I
feel like some people might be thrown
off that Jack Jack is still Jack Jack in
the timespan no I feel like that concept
works well when a sequel comes out
pretty soon after the first one like
pretty quickly after the first thing I'm
interested to see how this will play and
turn out for a film that comes out 13 or
14 years later and it takes place
immediately after the first one I wonder
if it's really gonna depend on you
strongly remembering the first one the
first one is amazing it is what I
remember about the first one it's
amazing yeah I remember beets of it but
I don't remember it like the full
details yeah it's been it's been like
maybe like eight years since I've seen
the first one that's a lot of people's
favorite Pixar movie I think it's one of
their best
yeah and it's it's exciting for this to
come back and I'm curious about how it's
gonna work out too because it has been
so long and it's not hard to revisit
things time has passed I think we're
slowly transitioning from 80s nostalgia
into 90s nostalgia I mean this isn't a
90s film however if you were a 90s child
this is one of your films yeah the irony
be description that I read for this was
that mr. incredible is taking care of
Jack Jack well alas the world saving the
world
like why is it that scenario it's an
interesting flip of parenting feminism
women saving the world that's important
like a bit more of a
contain the story I'm wondering if we're
gonna jump back and forth or yeah just
gonna spend the movie with mr.
incredible yeah Brad Burt he was on a
roll with Incredibles ratatouille Iron
Giant before all this then mi ghost
Protocol Denny like tomorrow I'm kind of
dipped that super strong streak box
office and critical wise now he's coming
back with Incredibles 2 I feel like he
does movies when he just wants to do
them but I'm wondering if the lack of
response in Tomorrowland kind of pushed
him to do the Incredibles too
I mean I'm sure it's got something to do
with why he's back in animation so soon
after that or why his next you know
major thing after that is enemies to
follow up we've been warning yeah yeah
yeah for sure out of all the Pixar
movies out there that could get a sequel
I think this is in the terms of this
teaser I'm excited to see what all of
Jack Jack's different powers end up
being and I like that logo yeah today's
patient the day shout-out Rosa para Rosa
Rosa my dear this woman has been part of
our patreon since the beginning avid
supporter and she has a lot of children
and she's a hard-working woman and right
now she's working double the hours she
did when we first knew her or she's
helping people out she's in the medical
field and she's helping people out now
she's when I save up so she can get a
house and really provide for her family
even more and still with all this and
not being able to participate in a lot
of the patreon exclusive things she is
still one of our top pledged patrons she
is one of the Rose best people I know
Thank You Rosa for being such a
hard-working woman a devoted mother a
devoted wife I hope that you're able to
completely succeed in getting the dreams
you want with getting that house so you
can run away from your entire family and
just be with John yes hey to be your man
and be your slave man
I hope is that thing slave man well it
is now but that's John Rosa I support
this decision what I do this shall give
a shout out and then I don't you
subscribe to the real
please click that notification bell you
can follow us on social media yeah
become a patron eject today people also
we're on the Stardust app and using it a
lot catching up on the Punisher and
posting reactions to each episode on
that so go follow us there as well